[Music]
m
no
the
[Music]
we're going to move on to the Cypriot news
Olivier Delamarche what
can you tell us about the situation in
Cyprus the astonishing, the side effects without the
mechanisms played by
Roger or not we were told it was over that it was
settled but I have
the impression that it's not at all we'll talk about it again soon we saw
that it was managed in the
stupidest way possible
we closed the Cypriot banks in
Cyprus but we forgot to close them in
London and as a result you have a good
part of the funds that have been exfiltrated
from the banks so as a
result we'll realize in a
few days or a few weeks that
the 6 billion we were supposed to recover
are not there and at that point we'll have to start all over again so as
usual as was done in
Greece as has been done
every time it was done
in spite  Common sense dictates that we
do things wrong, as usual,
and that results in the problem
not being solved at all, and that we talk about it
week after week for
months and months and months and months,
and that in a few months, one by one, we will arrive at a
problem like that of
Greece, with unfortunately
signals that have been given that will
trigger,
I think, a bank run in weak countries,
including France. Let's
not exclude ourselves from these countries. Let's say a
country leaves the European Union. The
country that has the euro will find itself
in other
central banks because these euros will become
toxic assets. Well, yes,
obviously, that will pose a serious
difficulty because
currently no process for
a country to leave the Eurozone exists. We
even see that in the texts, the rules, it probably serves
to
leave the European Union. We
see that we are still very far
from having flexible management at this level,
and I take it very seriously.  It's not entirely out of the question that Cyprus will be
one of the first countries where
an experiment to
exit the Eurozone will be attempted, with
the International
Bankers Association even pushing somewhat in this
direction. The difficulty,
of course, lies in the situation in
Cyprus, where a
Western perspective has led to debts three to four times
greater than what can
probably ever be repaid.
Since 2008, there has been a beginning of a return to
reality, but we are still in a
situation where lenders
obviously think they will be repaid, and
borrowers think that
they will never be able to repay, or at least that they won't be able to cope. They are resorting to
raising massive
taxes in the short term, taxes which,
if raised, would be
extremely destructive to
the economy.
Cyprus is the first country where
we are seeing a beginning of a return to reality, which
is that all its losses,
currently its accountant,
are being remitted to the public.
So,
obviously, Cyprus hasn't had
two dead plans this time.  impacting its
population, as Greece or
other countries have experienced, these plans have
always been financed by
additional debt. So in Cyprus, in Asia, they
no longer want to take on debt, and since they no longer
want to take on debt, the
system is bankrupt. And so,
everyone involved will take their losses,
obviously the bank shareholders first,
then the
bank bond lenders (there aren't
many in Cyprus), obviously the very
large depositors, and it's not guaranteed
beyond one hundred thousand euros.
So yes, Cyprus is a
small laboratory for this. Indeed, it's
extremely unpleasant for the
population, and no, it's catastrophic
what's happening in Cyprus.
Most companies are brooding because,
obviously, their cash flow is being depleted in the
same way, plus, let's say at
least, the medium to very large depositors.
Unfortunately, what else can we
do in this situation,
Bernard? Yes, just one word: it's a very
small problem, it's a problem. And
if the SKC Pinacci  Prince and 0.05
percent of European wealth, the
European GDP simply raises the question of our
principles in the event of an exit, which is that of expansion, like an
oil slick.
Those of the two consequences of this
exit vis-à-vis other states would be
much more significant in terms of
shares in European wealth, but above all,
the Cyprus story
demonstrates once again that we built
the euro by going against
common sense. We brought together
a number of completely
heterogeneous countries economically, countries that had
not reached the same
stage of maturity, and we created a
single currency
between them. The result is that, indeed,
a number of
countries are not capable of respecting
the discipline that results from this
currency, especially when it was
raised by
Germany's position. In fact, what should have been
done—it's obvious now,
but some have said it before—
is to wait until there was a minimum
of economic coherence between the
nations, and then how to bring
nations into the euro.  Having the same
economic status, the same
economic coherence, the same economic wealth,
is that what you think? Do you
think that Germany pushed for
weaker countries to join so
that the euro would have a weaker value? It's
easy to see why, given its exports. I don't
think so. I think Germany
has always supported a
strong currency policy, both during the Deutsche
Mark era and now with the euro.
The euro is, in a way, a
substitute for the Deutsche Mark for
the Germans, so they are
perfectly content with a
high level compared to other
major international currencies.
So they aren't looking for a decline at all.
Through this kind of phenomenon,
they have been caught in a kind of
trap, which I call infernal,
by which, moreover,
the European peoples don't
know the meaning of the same thing. We created,
being very dense, and led with
components of states
that had no
economic homogeneity, so all of this couldn't
hold up. All of this was going to explode one day.
Your interpretation of those who would have the
capacity to act, that is to say, Brussels, the
leaders, the main
European leaders, does their capacity
for action seem realistic to you given
the scale of the problem? The only way to
allow marginal states, if I may
say so economically, within the euro, the only
way to allow them to stay in
the euro, would be to lower the value of
the euro against others, as in other countries, to carry out
a devaluation, said
Boudreau, conquered, and in relation to the dollar,
for example, from 1.20 to 25, which all
economists have in mind and which, moreover, respects these
economic and financial ratios. But
how did you arrive at this? I don't believe that it is
the action of states that will
allow the situation, and the law is the law
of supply and demand that regulates
the parity of currencies every day, and once again, this is
the euro, and to a
large extent influenced by the
still brilliant health of Germany today,
Olivier, with the expectations in
terms of 2, how to say  of growth or
freeing it to Germany, is it if we only
train that, no, no, it's certain that
Germany wasn't going to, yes, compared
to others today, it is, it is doing
better,
the question is obviously when the
recession will spread to the other
surrounding countries which are its main
customers, obviously it will go badly,
its model is extremely
unbalanced, in fact extremely
focused on the greens, on exports,
I would have liked to react to the part
and to the part Rollin obviously I completely
share the vision, in particular,
which is an aberration to bring
countries such as obviously
Cyprus, well even the address, into
a monetary zone like
Europe, there is very little discussion on this
and where there can be one is
even, can we make a
single currency and enter between
countries, in any case, for it to work, what
are the conditions and do
these conditions exist in
Europe? I think it is impossible,
impossible, within a five-year timeframe, to
make a single currency between
France and Germany, for example,
why?  Obviously, when you
create a single currency, you
deprive yourself of tears of hunger, inevitably
of valuation, or at least depreciations,
to try to rebalance
divergent economies. If you create a
single currency, in case of
competitiveness gaps,
things will have to be rebalanced, and if there are more
possibilities to do something at the
level of currencies, it must be done at the
level of wages, of the
competitiveness of countries. In any case, we
need, firstly, to be countries
that are more or less capable of
reforming themselves, and secondly, to have
countries that have a vision no longer of
economic warfare but of
economic peace, just as today
Alsace is not trying to lower its
wages compared to
Midi-Pyrénées; it cannot work,
forced into this situation. So they need to have
a real vision of
cooperation. Today, the end of 15 years
of experience with the euro shows that we are, on the
contrary, in increasingly
divergent phases where each country does what it
wants without asking the opinion of
others.  Germany cut
wages in 2002-2003, not asking the
elderly to do the same. Ireland lowered its
corporate tax rate for
banks, not for others. France
implemented the 35-hour workweek and didn't ask
others to do the same, whether it was good or bad. In
any case, each country did what it
wanted without realizing that we
are all sharing a
common space. What about the currency,
sir? What
can you tell me about Ireland and
Irish taxation? Ireland is an
aberration. Ireland was
a country with
three sheep and
whiskey distilleries, okay, a pipe for poor countries, and
we brought it into the euro. So I completely
agree with
Olivier. We bring them into the euro,
we authorize them or not, or we
suggest it. I don't know exactly how
it happened, but secondly, to
create a quasi-free zone with a
tax on  12%, so in fact, we
introduced ourselves into the euro, a tax haven. That's exactly what it is.
We don't
talk about it much as a
tax haven today; we focus more on
Switzerland, but it is one. And
in fact, it can't work. That is to
say, we invest heavily there, but we
wait for it to blow over. And then, obviously, when
it created a bubble—a
real estate bubble, a bubble
in Ireland—and that bubble burst,
and we had to bail out the
banks, the Irish said, "Oh yeah,
but if we break the
12% tax model, we're finished." So
immediately, Europe went to hell in a handbasket. So we keep this
model. It's ridiculous; it can't
work. It can't
work. And this is the outline that
is astonishing. Or even, you talked about
the euro's structure, but that was much
later. We brought them into
the euro in 2008, so we know it doesn't
work.  We know there's a problem,
but we keep going. Bernard wouldn't have let
Cyprus in either.
Nobody knows that, that's the
tragedy. It's that no European, none of the
400 million Europeans, is aware of this. That's why we
created this very chic currency. And besides,
none of the 400 million Europeans
closely followed the process of developing
the euro and the fact that we put the
cart before the horse. That is to say, we should have
waited for greater
convergence between
the economies of the states wishing to
join this single currency before
creating it. We know that the United States
pushed the European Union to
expand. We saw it with
Turkey, the negotiations on Turkey. Do
you think the
United States pushed Europe to expand
either to weaken it economically
to regain leadership, or was it
pure and simple altruism?
Initially, the Americans, and especially
Kissinger, when he was
Secretary of State, were involved.  The state's support for Nixon, in
particular, was effectively rejected during the
creation of Europe for a very
simple reason, and I
believe it's important to respect it. He wanted to
definitively end the tensions that had arisen during the bloody
conflicts that had plagued
European countries in the past. They
wanted to avoid a repetition
of the conflicts that led to
the Second World War, and also to the
First, for that matter. And then, did
they push
massively for expansion? Yes, for reasons I don't know, to be
honest, to
weaken Europe.
I think we shouldn't always accuse
states of Machiavellianism.
Unfortunately, sometimes, in Bouaké, the state is less
Machiavellian. We imagine Olivier the Raja, or
why Cyprus? I
simply think it was brought in
unconsciously. So, just as we created
the euro unconsciously, when we dig
a little deeper, we see why we
created the euro as a political symbol.
European integration is a
nice symbol of political integration, its
practices of having a single currency in
the zone. The difficulty is that it has
extremely heavy consequences on
economies after 10 to 15 years. Besides, we would let them
do it, but no, it's very simple
today to go for a single currency
between Europe and China:
1. We agree with the
Chinese leaders to create a central bank;
3. It likes euros in the zone, it's
not complicated. However, after
ten years you will realize
that while unemployment in Europe is at 25%, things are
better in China. But that is to
say, it takes a lot of time to
see the negative consequences of a
very nice political decision. We
continue, by the way, Latvia
with 10 withdrawals on January 1st or the 14th,
it will be continuous, and that means
we have a problem. We know that the euro
is still very, very sick
today, even if afterwards we can
always say that  What will explode, what won't, it doesn't
matter. We have a
sick currency, a
sick system, a system in which
we're getting more and more indebted
trying to bail out this or that country, and
today all we can think
to do is keep letting
countries into the Eurozone. It's against all common
sense to let countries into the
Eurozone. They'll tell me, "Yes,
we committed to it," but whatever. We have a
problem today, and instead of trying
to solve it, we're trying to make it
worse. So what I remember most is that what's
crazy is that,
for example, we haven't even been given a
rule for joining the
Eurozone to have, for instance, an
average salary at least equal to the
Eurozone average or a corporate tax rate
at least equal to the average,
to stop dragging things down and
increasing the divergences within the zone. One
last point about Latvia, which is
already being called the future Cyprus, by the way.
Because it's obviously a country with
very low taxes, which is
true, and 9% of Latvians are in favor of
joining the Eurozone, but still, it's
fantastic. Behind
Latvia, four or five floors are being built,
no, but what an effect! We
see a whole bunch of several
European states, the UCIA, Poland, but I
think they're showing wisdom. Yes,
exactly. I'm coming back to the
deer and the bank deposit guarantee fund. Is it
properly provisioned? Have there been
exercises to be able to
implement it quickly,
simulations to put it in place? Do
you think that the public authorities,
at least the French ones, are able to
guarantee to the French that if a state
or their
bank defaults, their
euro savings will be guaranteed up to
100 million?
The guarantee fund isn't very
big, it only has
billions of euros currently. What does "
not very big" mean?
By admin, billions more or less of deposits, and
the fund is 2  Billions, that being said,
you still have a buffer
concerning uninsured deposits,
representing roughly 500 billion in
total. So, in other words, even if there aren't
500 billion in losses and only two of the
major depositors haven't left the
banking system, you can still absorb a great many
shocks.
What's more troubling, by the way, is the
deposit guarantee fund. We've
barely mentioned it in the current banking law; it's being
merged with a
guarantee fund, or rather a
resolution fund, which is supposed to help
banks in difficulty.
In other words, we're
mixing funds that were meant
solely to
protect depositors' savings
with a fund that could be used to
recapitalize Crédit Agricole or
Société Générale tomorrow, whereas it would have been
much healthier to create two
separate funds, as Europe allowed.
Speaking of funds, Mr. de la
Marche, what do you think of
the European Central Bank's equity? The
European Central Bank's equity... I don't know, it's
not a problem since
nothing has nothing  Nevertheless, we've
seen it many times, so nothing
prevents printing money.
Therefore, from that point on, the
balance sheets of central banks and their equity
capital aren't particularly important. That's the
only thing
we can say. Today,
you saw what happened with the so-
called
EC2 regulation of Greece, the haircut. What happened?
Why did we create
an air code that was, in fact, quite limited—
I remind you, limited—
to the obliques that were under Greek law, and
not to the obliques under
international law that obligate the hobbies of
Greek law bonds, that is to
say, issued under Greek law, so basically
held only by
Greek banks? Everything
issued under international law was not
affected by the haircut. But above all,
the ECB said yes, I'm fine with it
for the private sector, but not
for me, because between what they
had directly in the...
Greek sovereign bonds plus the
collateral they had accepted, it
amounted to 200 billion.
Okay, so 100 billion, 75% makes
150. The ECB's equity, if I
remember correctly, should be around 13
billion, I think.
13 billion - 150, that's
still a big hole and it's
messy,
so there you go. But today,
otherwise
we're also talking about this on the
Fed's balance sheet. No matter the Fed's balance sheet, it
can, it could, at the limit,
almost double. You just have to print what's
needed. Mr. Bernanke isn't
a great specialist in this. They've given us
4 billion every day.
If needed, they'll give us 8. I've
committed. I see you smiling. No, no, I
am
indeed  Fortunately,
what keeps things running is, in a
way, the American printing press,
because it injects liquidity
into the system, and that allows
interest rates to remain low.
All of this is part of the lottery, his own, during
the crisis, but not in the
clumsy economy. In economics, the
funds, the funds issued by the
American central bank, the Fed, still are
n't reaching the real economy.
Why is a pope, at what it's worth
today, staying in the
financial economy? Well, it's getting there
because it's one of the six directly,
but it's true that it serves to fuel
speculative futures for the most part, and
it's not for nothing that
the American stock market is still hungry and returning to its
pre-crisis levels.
It's still so realistic,
you really think these funds are
there to maintain the various
stock market indices, Hassan Haddad? But it's in
decline, we told you, he said it
officially, he said
it only serves one purpose: to make it
rise on Monday. So it's good, there isn't, there isn't  There are no
other reasons.
I don't know if you remember, but back
in 2011, the Bank
of England asked a
number of experts for a report, asking what the
consequences were, what
portion
of its quantitative easing had
returned to the economy. If you
remember what happened, after a
while, the experts came back to
the Bank of England, gave
their report, saying that barely 3%
of the quantitative easing had entered
the real economy. The Bank of England's
conclusion was simple: let's do a
second round. It worked so well, and it's a good thing
it didn't return to
the economy, because given the massive amounts
injected, its share would make my
inflation level, which is still
significant, suffer. A major bond bubble in the
current system of low interest rates
would be catastrophic for
the accounts of the banks and
their cronies. Simon, a
quick word on
Japan's quantitative easing policy: what do
you think, sir? Exemplary
policy...
Quantitative easing is following
the policy to print or
devalue its currency. Well, I didn't have any
idea. The Japanese show is so
current on Japan, he just committed
suicide. What? Why is he arousing
more and more interest? I drank, I saw a
statement from
Mr. AB this weekend, or to immunize
finances, it doesn't matter
who announces it, it's a kind of one-upmanship. It's like
two teenagers in the
schoolyard. A series of measures is the one
who goes the furthest. Sika Health
Interview knows the former
Japanese finance minister. If you had to
ask him a question,
what questions would you ask him?
Bees are judging each other, how far they will go
in the south, that is to say, there they seem to be
accelerating
things quite a bit, I tell you, they are in the process of
being in competition with Mr.
Bernanke, it's about who buys back
the most bonds.
They announced figures that
are totally astounding, so
you're going to have, I think everyone is
bloody today because
the  The yen had gone from 81.13 on
this good news to 98. I think we haven't seen the last of it
falling, and that it
really is, for once,
a monkey's currency. That is to
say,
central bankers really need to
stop thinking that by playing
Monopoly they can fix an
economy. They're in the middle of a game of Monopoly, in a full-blown cash grab, a full-blown
cavalcade, and it's going to end
very badly, sir.
It's a completely
mysterious phenomenon, I mean, created at the beginning of
the pause that was initially called the "
Japan pause." I played it; I felt that it was certainly...
I don't think it's
mysterious, for a monkey
view, it's a competitive devaluation
between... I'm going to take three major
blocs: Japan, Europe, and the
United States, and I'll get you to jump on that. On
the subject of economic warfare, Mr.
Bérurier, the message to say is indeed, it was
an act of
economic warfare through devaluation, but it
goes much further than that since  It's
really about triggering
inflation to a certain level, and it's a real pain.
Given the levels that are being
printed, and I'm going back to what I was
saying earlier, when you have
two to three times more debt than
you'll ever be able to repay, your
situation is quite desperate. So
you continue your gamble as long as
it works, and how do you get out of it? Either
you really try to raise those
sums in the form of taxes, and that
part triggers a recession, which
will increase anyway, along with
deficits; or you default like the
Greeks, saying, "Oh
no, excuse me, I really can't
repay, let's renegotiate and see what
loss you'll take"; or
you actually try to play with
your central bank to repay in worthless
currency by using the
printing press, but that's a form
of aid. There also needs to be
inflation for Hamburg, yes,
obviously, that's what
I think will happen
first where it's possible. Don't
ask too much in Europe, but in the
United States, in Japan, it's...  It's quite logical
that this is happening because why is it
easier, in quotes, even
if it's more instructors for
the economy, it's undoubtedly the most
unjust,
managed by political cowardice, it's better to
start with that, it's
political cowardice, obviously
political cowardice is an art, not daring to
renegotiate his debt and say it, but I'll
repay you by printing
colossal sums and Saturday after, there's a real
problem, changed, so I didn't come, the
solution for me, that this country has
experienced an absolutely frenzied ride
for the economy, that starting from
very low, one day the
Western standard of living in Dr. Raucourt and
relaxation, annual growth of the order of
7 to 10%, and then suddenly everything
stopped, and it's been a good fifteen years since
this stop, during which the blues have made people say it's the
warrior's rest, in a way, the
Japanese, a pause
in growth, and not at all, it's
a complete stop, they haven't, they can't get out,
and they have
experienced, I don't  I know how many
prime ministers have had economic policies,
and it still doesn't seem as if, in a
way, the Japanese
were made to climb
very steep mountains, but not at all
to manage a plateau. Don't you
think we're facing two
phenomena, and Japan is somewhat
ahead of us, showing the way,
which is that, firstly,
the economy was developing, and it's
beautiful, there's pretty much everything
needed on average for the
population. It's difficult to make
an economy grow that has already
grown. And secondly, it's an aging economy, it's
an aging population, it
's decreasing.
So, besides the decline in the
number of people and especially the
aging population, it's a
much less dynamic economy than in the
past, and therefore reaching a kind of
growth plateau is
relatively logical, and I think that's what's in
front of us. The question
is, why don't we think about what we
do when we're in
a zero-growth regime? We see  That
today there is an
almost fundamentalist refusal, have you considered
that it's not a refusal but rather
a group formed with a style
of thinking? And like them, they
will continue to think, or at least
try to perpetuate this system of
thought. They haven't learned to think
outside the box. But that's what
I call a denial of reality. I mean, I'm
37 years old. Growth went off to
buy cigarettes before
I was even born. It arrived, and we
keep saying "next year" and "it
will be here." We're going to have to say it won't
come back to us and adopt
the economic model. It's dramatic. It's stupid. Not
only are we obviously doing nothing,
but we're not even there yet. Well, we
refuse to think about it. There's practically
no economist in France who
thinks about what to do with
zero growth. You can't find a
thesis, you can't find funding
to reflect on this obsession, not an
economist or a politician. Look at the
statements of the Minister of Finance,
Mr. Moscovici, who says
yes to it.  It doesn't mean anything else, so
whoever says we'll have zero growth in 2013
and puts 1.3% in 2014 and 2% in 2015, that's it, we're back to square one
like in 2014, so that's what it will be like.
You'll see that at the beginning of 2014, he'll say, "Oh well,
yes, I have to admit that we're
still at zero, even negative," and "
But don't worry, in 2015 we'll
pick up again, and in 2016 we'll have 3%
growth." It's always the same thing, it's been going on for
twenty years, as
Olivier says. So, because we haven't
realized that, in fact, while for years the 2014
curve hasn't reversed, which was constructed by some
American economist, I don't remember which one,
who said that since 1950 we've lost one
percent of our population every ten years, we've lost one percent of our
growth every ten
years, so we'll have to get used to it.
Today we're no longer in a
system where we had growth through
demographics; that's over in
many countries.  It's not just over in
Japan, it's over in Germany, it's over in the
United States, it's over in China
with their one-child policy, it's over in
a large part
of the world, and you have, in addition to
helping, everything related to
industrialization, internal combustion engines,
electricity, etc., which doesn't
reproduce today. So
today, it's not because your
iPad is going to be twice as fast that it's going to
change the world and bring
you growth and
productivity. So the only productivity
we know today is
firing people, and that generally leads to
a small return on investment, on the topline,
on the revenue, which happens
quite quickly. I would like
your opinion on this. There's a formula
that could be applied in Japan by
Einstein, which applies to the
Aquila, itself applied to
fundamental physics, and which is the following:
think outside the box. Well, I wonder if
this formula wouldn't deserve to be
applied to  The economy,
especially Japan's, is rebounding. That's a
very good phrase too. Who said that we don't
solve problems with the
same thinking that created them? That's
exactly it. It's a
common thought. Also, Jacques Blanc,
I'm going to ask you a question about the
main macroeconomic players.
Have indicators been
misused, or is it a deficiency
in the interpretations of journalists and politicians? Do
you think
these indicators are still effective
for a correct reading? What
can you tell me about that?
UFR hardly talked about
indicators and practically only mentioned one
called growth.
Internal growth, and
growth, talking about an increase in the
gross domestic product, isn't uninteresting,
but the problem is that this
single indicator is extremely perfect. It's basically
the equivalent of
revenue for
companies. Imagine analyzing
companies just by looking at their
revenue and saying, "I hope the
revenue goes up soon."
You never look at whether the result is
positive or negative, but what if the  The
result is negative, the lines between revenue and GDP are opaque.
You
never account for the fact that
you're depleting natural resources like
oil, and you don't account for the
pollution you generate. You
talk about oil, but did you
know about the peak of UBS and the rapid pace of
oil production? Do you
think the debts issued by these
Ponzi schemes, these
state-sponsored ones, are a way to escape
the geological reality of energy?
Yes, so Alpiq deliberates at 17.67 yen.
It's a mathematical function that says
that from the moment you have a
finite stock of something and you use it,
when you have
production, it will rise, and then one day
it will reach zero
when you're finished. So it goes through
a maximum
and then it falls again. And Hubert
showed that on oil fields,
it actually makes a nice, somewhat bell-shaped curve,
relatively symmetrical.
So far, no, we haven't reached the
global peak, which could  Changing
things doesn't necessarily have a peak; there will probably be
a plateau that will
last, probably about ten years.
It's a peak that moves, yes, well, an
Olympic peak that moves a little,
but anyway, we see your
plateau will last roughly between
2010 and 2020. That's roughly what we have. This
gentleman, I'm in D1. You were
close to the powers that be when the
first oil shock arrived.
How did the
French institutions behave to manage this
new phenomenon?
The first oil shock took place in
the autumn of 1973. It was very
brutal. It resulted, in the event
published today, in a decline in the
world's GDP. At the end of
1974, most major developed countries saw a
2% drop. Recognizing what we
had experienced, what we have experienced recently,
I would say, then growth resumed. What we
have experienced, what we are very, very
weak. How did what we have, like those we
have known, or what we are  In
short, we are getting to know
your background. There is a certain
parallelism regarding the
fall in GDP between the first
oil crisis, and also the second one, that
of 2019-2010. Unfortunately, the
current situation has nothing to do with the oil crisis,
but in terms of economic situations, they
are extremely different.
How did we manage this? First, we managed it proactively.
That is to say, in a
certain way, in France,
we saw it coming, we had seen it coming,
since we
tried to protect ourselves against this
rise in oil prices by launching a
large-scale nuclear program. It is quite
implausible if they wanted to... if you
look at it with...
how to say... look at it today...
today, in a few
years, we have built, launched 30
nuclear power plants. We have done something
extravagant, something we will never do again. Was this
thought out before launching these thirty
centers? So yes, absolutely, it was carefully considered.
The occasion will require several
advisors to remain at the Élysée Palace, which was
presided over by the Head of State, Georges
Pompidou. In this instance, I have to
prepare a report for you, and I have drafted
summaries of the decision, which had been
corrected by the Head of State. All
these summaries are from this restricted council meeting
between Lyon and 69. They anticipated
the possibility of a future rise in the price of
oil and the excessive dependence
we had on oil for
our energy supply,
and this is what led to the launch of the
massive Duclair Plan, on which
we still live to a
large extent today. How did
other countries behave? Did
you have any perception of the
intelligence services, for example, the German or
Spanish? Were these
intelligence services interested in your
work, or were you alone
against us? It wasn't
specifically about the education services;
our work was public. I reported on
each restricted council meeting to the
journalist accredited to the Élysée Palace as soon as the
restricted council meeting ended.
to observe our decisions and our
decisions were
indeed very clear, they have been imitated in
several countries, but the Americans
did not wait for the call,
a nuclear program was also launched
before us, okay, but not on the same
scale in the building sector, so countries focused on
oil, sir. I'm going to
ask you a question, I'll
try to be very simple:
all these debts issued in our eyes
are not based on any energy or
calorific reality, that is to say, 1
dollar, 1 euro is worth the same number of calories.
We summarize purchasing power by
the number of calories bought or
assimilated. Do you think that
central banks are aware
that currencies and money are not based
on any energy reality? Well,
knowing what
Mr. Bernanke or anyone else is aware of is
complicated,
but
whoever they are aware of, that in any
case the currency they issue is
based on nothing, I think they
know that today. It's exactly
as if to explain to people a little what it is
because we talk a lot about
quantitative easing, printing money,
etc., in
general, and people  They don't understand much of what's being said,
but
it's exactly as if today
you had someone who liked 4
billion bad checks a day,
that is to say, checks based on nothing. If you're
sure that the guy writing you a check
in front of you has the funds in his
account, it's worth something. You can
go and exchange your check for
something, for a car, for anything.
From the moment
people start thinking there's
nothing in their account, for their currency, the
currency will collapse. And so
today I think he's
perfectly aware of this.
The systems, I think the
Japanese Prime Minister is also
aware of this. It's been going on for twenty years, he's been in office for
20 years, but who's been printing money? It's been
years since there's been growth, and we
're rich. As the
ultimate weapon to restart
the economy, Mr. Berneau has been leading us on
for five years. We say, "I'm going to
make things beautiful, lower unemployment thanks to
my quantitative easing." Very well, that  That's false.
We can clearly see that he hasn't
restarted the machine. We can clearly see that
today we're facing the
United States. It's a drug addict
with a lone hand who's taking
4 billion a day of cabbage, that's all.
Mr. Verrier, what do you think,
key, is the predatory behavior of the
United States in their foreign policy? A
cycle of predatory behavior in
debt issuance will be sustainable without
minor disruptions in other
economies. There are
already disruptions in
this economy. It's not for nothing that
Brazil is
also taking measures to limit the inflow
of American capital because
part of it is obviously fleeing the
United States. The United States has the
world's reserve currency, which gives them the
ability to do things we won't have in the
same way.
They also export part of their
inflation.
But what's interesting in all this is that we're
facing numerous
bubbles:
[Music]
monetary bubble, asset bubble,
bond oil that only rests on  On
confidence, 5 for the moment and
confidence always the system holds this
amazing trade when we talk about arms,
the gibbons 10, like just anything, have
united, still triple A
for several rating agencies. I
use a bunch of rating agencies that have
circumvented in such a desperate situation.
Confidence is there, and indeed,
as it lasts, we have policies, in
fact, what they  They say it's not a big deal,
well, we printed 2 billion a day on the
market, you see, it's not a huge amount, but let
's try three times in four,
now Japan, 10 times in eight.
The problem is that confidence and
binary options, there are some, there aren't, it's
not about confidence this Monday, then Tuesday, a little bit on
Wednesday, then a lot, I
say no, really, we're like in
those children's games where the
little pyramids, you take turns removing something
and
then it holds, it holds, it's like in the movie "Les
Ch'tis," everything collapses, and that's what's likely
to happen by
doing whatever we want with currencies, by
doing whatever we want with the
markets. But one day it won't work anymore, indeed, there will be
a politician
who will say, "But it's crazy, it worked
for 25 years, I did just a tiny bit
more and it didn't
work at all anymore," because the day we'll say that we should do
better than them,
our salary by converting it to
Swiss francs 1, because we'll see people
who  Things are going to get agitated at the
central bank; this is going to pose serious problems.
The yen has fallen, certainly the Japanese
have lost 20% of their international purchasing power
in just a few
weeks following the statements.
Indeed, we haven't seen anything yet, but
Mr. Lambert, in the event of a widespread loss of
confidence, what do you think
could happen?
A collapse of economies? All I've
observed in the past, from the
vantage point I've found myself in, is that
economies
function well at
relatively high and satisfactory growth rates when
they combine increased investment, the
country's economic activity, and consumption.
When only consumption
or only investment is working, we
have periods of mediocre growth,
in addition to content. On the other hand, when
both engines
work together, the economy
is on a relatively sustained growth trajectory.
Of course, if we manage to maintain confidence,
today in most major
developed countries, and particularly in the
other, a confidence that allows for a
return to investment,
which is something that companies
absolutely do not practice.  For the moment,
for several reasons,
firstly because they lack confidence,
and secondly because they don't
necessarily have the means;
their self-financing rate is
dramatically low and has plummeted in recent
years. If we manage to
revive this confidence, I think we can
reconnect with a certain form of
trust, and this form of trust
can also be reflected in the fact that
the savings, passed on by people in
France in particular, but it's true a bit
everywhere in Europe I think, will be
broken. These savings, currently
intended to
protect against unemployment, haven't been able to
speak out. We'll break
the savings, and Rocco Samora believes that once
confidence has returned, which will allow for a
return to investment,
we will finally have
stable, relatively vigorous real growth.
But it will no longer be like the growth we've
seen in
the past; it will be 2 to 2.5 percent, I
imagine. So, at most, you're talking about
confidence,
confidence.  What do you
think of the business that Jacques
Senez, a phenomenon that has died, remains immense? It
introduced an instant drop in confidence,
and I
reread them more often. This affair, which has had
its order of ethics and morality in
our societies currently, and which
results from the fact that every day, every
month, you see a huge scandal.
What they accepted, however small,
compared to a hormone a few
years ago, compared to Goldman Sachs, compared
to Morgan Stanley, compared to
Deutsche Bank, compared to the LIBOR problem,
every day you have somewhere
the announcement of a
profound, fundamental breach of ethics, and
ultimately all this no longer affects
anyone. It serves only that we are here, we look at
all this with completely
jaded eyes without questioning what all
this means. Even if Olivier Delamarche,
Mr. Lambert, spoke of LIBOR, what
can one tell me about Lebanon
for anything
else? It is indeed a scandal that
we have. What was this scandal? Not bad,
not bad.
Ultimately, it was hushed up since it's being talked about less
and less. A few banks
paid a small fine to get
rid of it,
but it's them. It's like everything else, like
all these
scandals: we talk about them for a few
days, a few
weeks in
the media. These are things—at least as far as
LIBOR is concerned—that don't directly affect
people because it's complicated to
understand how they manipulated
things, and so people
quickly forget. And in fact, these are scandals involving
tens and hundreds of billions, settled discreetly
with a
small fine. Mr. Bernier, what surprises me
in all this is that we're surprised. For
thirty years we've been in
a very clear ideology
of ultra-liberalism or libertarianism,
which basically says there's an
invisible hand of the market, which, above all, I
want to say—but wait—only has
the personal behavior of being
selfish, and we're not told...  The point
of having ethical guidelines or a
meal, whether you're a Gaullist or not, it'll be fine,
but this rule, his rule, isn't based
on any ethical criteria. What does it encourage? It encourages
dishonesty, inevitably. In any case, the
condition is that you can tell yourself, "
My goal isn't to be honest, my goal is that no one
knows I'm being dishonest,"
which is very different. So
every time you think you can
be dishonest without getting caught,
you do it because that's
your criterion. Try it against the Duke
Times, where Enron is found, and
every time, over the past ten years, it's strange
that these companies, we realize they don't care about
us, and the same goes
for the banks. And yet,
logically, when you
look in detail,
you realize that all the
people who are slightly
implicated, with a few scandals
behind them, have exactly the same
background. We always find
very high-ranking people in finance, we
always find people who have gone through
institutions of power. I'm in
green, what do you think? Is it  Do
you think there's a real
attraction at higher levels
to cover up the scandals that
have allowed us to reach a certain level
of responsibility?
These people, who are part of the fear
class as you say, simply have the
power to make
significant ethical breaches,
but there are others at lower levels.
I don't think it's
limited to a segment of the population.
The problem is that there are 50 without proof,
meaning it's become
commonplace. So, they know this leads to a
certain
number of people joining cults, people who no longer believe in
anything, so they rush towards
cults or religious extremism.
I believe we can't
continue to survive this way. I have a somewhat
crazy idea: for me,
survival is about recreating a
minimum of ethics from this liberalism that
is without faith or law,
and that we need to establish rules of
conduct. So how do we create this
ethical code? Well, by bringing together a
number of people,
each representing a different school of
thought.  The human race, including the
major monotheistic religions (
Buddhism, Hinduism), the devout,
agnostics, freethinkers, and
Freemasons, perhaps adding a
few cheeses, a few Nobel
Peace Prizes, and a few Nobel Prizes in
science, must
create a kind of council. If a limited
number of respected people enter,
as much as possible, so that
their work is effective, a council that makes
each of the seven billion individuals on
the planet feel represented by one of
them. And it would require that, through a
kind of spontaneous outpouring—you
see the difficulty of the operation—this
council, this conclave, lays down the tablets of
the law of liberalism, that is to say,
four or ten pages of great
scope, definitively condemning unjust
enrichment,
child trafficking, and
child labor, so that
children enter the workforce only when
they have acquired a minimum of
intellectual autonomy. It definitively condemns
inequalities between men and women. And so, we
all have these tablets of the law without  The spirit, in a
way, they aren't codified, and
I dream, I fantasize about a conclave
of people of this nature, of this caliber, who
developed them. So I'm actually working on it
with UNESCO, with an association called
the Fraternity of Abraham,
perhaps with the Institut de
France, and I haven't given up hope of
organizing such a meeting sometime in
2014.
I hope you haven't connected
with Wayne, unfortunately. You were
talking about Freemasonry, why
put Freemasons around a
table? Because their training is a
way of thinking that shouldn't be
neglected. I'm not into
Freemasonry, but it so happens that I was
invited to give a lecture
in front of, I don't remember, El Gran Torino
and Franck Pellerot,
on economic warfare, after which
I attended a
cocktail party of this obedience, and I
found the atmosphere of this lodge
warm and friendly. Hello, it's a
way of thinking that doesn't shock me.  I'm not
part of it because I didn't want to
benefit from it,
but there you have it. So I wouldn't want to neglect
any form of contemporary thought,
including the people represented at this
conclave. You're talking about roundtables on the
internet. We're aware of an
organization called the Bilderberg Group. What
can you tell us
about the Beagles? Berck, the town of Berck, is it
like the Trilateral Commission, like Davos? They're a kind of reputable
club where you can find
major
international bankers, big breasts, and
top business leaders of all kinds—
industrial and service-oriented.
I think the media are present at
these kinds of meetings. In some, I
think so. The town of Bern has held a
thousand Merckx meetings. Will it
massively register the thousand? The mayor, I don't remember
anymore. I must have participated once or twice a
very long time ago.
As for the Trilateral Commission, I don't feel
guilty about, how to
say, having shared
shameful secrets. It's very
simple. So you have here
business leaders, grand banquets,
major financiers...  Politicians
arrive with their credo of
liberalism,
they talk at length for two or
three exhausting days, and leave having
engraved
the modalities of this liberalism on some kind of hard drive. So,
it
slightly improves the functioning of these
liberalisms, alas, not enough to
avoid the excesses we just discussed.
So let's not give
excessive importance to these kinds of meetings.
The striking advance, I mean,
going in this direction, nothing. I participated in
a completely different experience in Nantes. In
Davos, one day, the president of Davos, the
creator,
called me and told me, Bernard Curé, to create
a group of what we will call the
Academic Lieders, on the occasion of
the next
Davos meeting. It will consist of the presidents of the 15
largest universities in the world.
And so I was very flattered by his
initiative. I read that, as president
of the École Polytechnique, he did indeed bring
fifteen presidents of
major educational institutions to
Davos. GT2, general rapporteur of the group,
and  He told us, "Well, listen, prepare
a message for humanity." So we locked ourselves away
for 48 hours.
I tried to write in
broken English. It's a synthesis of your
work, and we actually drafted
a four- or five-page message that
covered the themes I just
mentioned:
child labor, gender equality, the
elimination of illicit enrichment,
etc., plus a few other
messages on education and the training
of men in general. We took all of that
to Mr. Claude Fabre, the director of
Davos, who put it in a drawer and
closed it at Clide, to our super
faction, and who told us, "No, Davos didn't like a
message." So there you have it, there are no
messages within these
structures. There are simply a kind of
near-consensus that transforms into a
more pronounced consensus at the end of the
meetings. I see you
smiling,
yes, because all these meetings
are just for empty promises.
Nothing ever comes of them, just like the G20, just like
the meetings of the...  The IMF is the same, it
never gets anything out of it. We get
sensational declarations, but Ms.
Lagarde or someone
else says nothing.
So I'd say it's business as usual.
We're being led astray
today.
I said it last week on BFM.
Anyway, the sheep have to
stay quiet so we can
bury them. We have to
give them, we have to
give them a little lullaby
so we can
shear them peacefully. So that's what's being done. That's what's being
done when
we give figures that are false, completely
false. We're talking about unemployment figures,
growth figures,
figures... we do it
constantly. Speaking
of unemployment figures, the figures from
Friday...
hiccup... in the United States, a dismaying thing is that we
continue to do
exactly the same thing, as we have for
several months, even several
years, making
people disappear. There are
630,000 Americans who
suddenly disappeared. That is to say, we
lower the voter turnout rate.  This is
possible given the labor force's low level of unemployment, which has never
been so low. And
if you compare that to the average labor force
participation rate,
if you compare that to
the average today, there are 11.6%
unemployed in the United States. Okay, so
if you take the figure after expanding it,
which is what they call the EU-
6 component—that is, people
who work a few hours per share
per month—you end up
with an unemployment rate close to
10.9%, or rather, 1 in 5, still, right?
And then when you look at
the details, you see that unemployment
has never lasted so long. You
see that there have never been so many
fixed-term contracts,
temporary contracts, etc. You see
that
since 2008, we have created 4 million
jobs in the United States for those over
55,
and that, on the other hand, for those under 55, that is,
young Americans,
we have lost three million.  Jobs are disappearing,
but nobody seems bothered, and we keep
telling you, "Oh, but the United States is
full of
reindustrialization." We look at the
figures, and we realize that we're laying off
everyone every year in the manufacturing sector. We
live for
a month, every month, we lay people off,
and we tell you, "But we've
reindustrialized!" No, that's false. And
today, we haven't
hired a single person. In other words,
quantitative easing hasn't produced any
decrease in unemployment at all.
That's completely false, and that's part
of those figures. So, we're pulling the same trick on you,
I'm sure we're doing the same thing with
housing in the United States, where
banks are seizing
the homes they've confiscated to
prevent the
market from continuing to fall. So, they end up
with stocks of
unsold properties today, due to
bank retention of assets. And
obviously,
everything is like that. We have a
knack for it, clearly.  We wonder
if analyst firms sometimes
do their job. Sometimes, they even
try
to compare figures here,
because, well,
regarding
the precise figures, the analyst firms aren't doing
their job. Are the
journalists behind them
now also not doing their job? But that's not their
job; it's primarily the job of
analyst firms, strategists,
and economists to do it. Then the
journalist is there to get the
strategists to say this, but it's not
their job to go looking for that.
They could do it, but they don't. There were
inconsistencies everywhere. That is to
say, we are
also looking at the inconsistencies that perpetuate the
myth of
American energy independence. If you look at shale
gas production,
you realize that
you're being sold a load of nonsense that will
probably be very indigestible. So,
simply put, we need to look into
things, we need to try to work.  Just a little bit, that's
Paris for you, it's tiring, but you're in pain.
You're talking about energy transition,
Mr. Lambert. How do you plan to
finance the
energy transition in France, in
Europe, and worldwide under these conditions? This whole
pyramid of government debt has
n't helped its citizens finance
this transition. The financing of
energy imports has always been
done through exports; I know, that was
their raison d'être from the
start. The
first balance of trade,
40-50 years ago, was a very simple trade balance. On
one side, there were
energy
and pre-final imports, and then exports of
products intended to cover those imports. So,
gradually,
starting in 1962, a
second balance of trade in
industrial products was added to this first balance. And so,
the weight of exports went
from a few percent of the
national wealth of the GNP to 20% by the 1970s.
Since then, as international trade has
continued to grow,
a third  This balance is added to the
first two, or even a fourth. We are now at
approximately
40% of the weight of international trade in our wealth. This
means that, on average, we work
almost one day out of two for exports and one day out of two for
imports.
So, all of this has always been
resolved in this way, for us
French in particular, with a surplus
in our foreign trade.
Incidentally, to make a
brief aside, it is this
voracious increase in international trade, which
has grown by about 7% more than
global wealth in real terms. On the
ground, we have an enormous 27%. That means
per year, that means a doubling in ten
years. This, moreover, means that the share
of
international trade in global wealth has doubled. This is what led me
to develop this theory of
economic warfare, because it is through these
exports and
imports that we have spread the virus of
competitiveness, which itself has driven
all the economies that participated
in this significant growth of 5-6%
during  20 years, then two enemies, 3%
following, and that's what allowed this
enrichment, but what about the
cruelty and the arrogance of letting considerable
income disparities persist,
the financing of the
energy transition in France, what do
you think of the wishes?
Could you also explain to Hunter
the price signal? What does
the price signal mean in terms of
financing
itself? And this is a topic
we talk about a lot:
France's assets are worth 13 trillion euros. I
think we have enough to finance
energy transitions. We know that it won't
start until, indeed, at
level 2, in terms of prices, you have
a price for bread, a bus, a
liter of gasoline at 3 or 4 euros. And then, don't worry,
when it happens—and it will happen
much faster than we think—
you will inevitably need to
convert your economy a bit. On the
contrary, I also want to say
it's an important topic. It's
good to think about it a little. It's not an
urgent matter, I swear. Jean Cerner, faced with
a pyramid of debt that is going to collapse,
we are facing a European currency that
is on the verge of collapse, and nobody knows
how we'll get out of it without
colossal damage.  I think that's where we'll need to
put a certain amount of energy,
thought, and reflection to build on what was
said earlier.
I also wanted to make a couple of
minor remarks on
different levels, concerning ethics and
behavior. What strikes me is that when we're
also in an era where there's been a
gigantic weakening of
collective values—
very amusing, forty years ago you
had battles fought roughly
between a
right-wing Catholic ideology and a left-wing
communist ideology, very different in
appearance but which, in any case, emphasized
the collective—we realize that both have
collapsed, that they've been
replaced by nothing but an
ideology of individualism: act well,
be selfish, think only of yourself, everything will be fine. Just
like in '89, we saw the
collapse of a world where only
the collective was valued and
individual freedoms were completely eliminated. Well, here we are...
Seeing it collapse, probably
my good friend, is nothing but
individual freedom and no longer any sense of
community. Being a beggar is what you
lack to build connections and to become a professional, to build a
society. I don't have the
answer, but this lack is
undoubtedly a structuring factor in what's
happening today. Second thought:
on the
ground, always more, one step at a time, growth
was rapid, always more, always more
goods, always more
growth. There's also a
financial aspect, always more
money, always higher
salaries. And when you see the
evolution of
executive compensation in large companies, it's
quite fabulous. For 80 years,
I've had ratios of 120 to 40 between the
CEO and the company's business salary,
so suitable for 400, but there are companies, that is to
say, going from
quite cleanly to 8000, it's madness. And it's
something that, in my opinion,
really strikes at the very foundations of
capitalism and darkens its
acceptance. So I hope there will
also be developments in this area.  It's
probably more brutal than I would have liked,
but we see that when you
want to impose a 75% tax rate on
salaries that
are already exorbitant for Bondy employees,
it's unconstitutional, it's not possible.
Perhaps we'll have to
limit them a bit more, a bit more
drastically, at the level of, I repeat,
employees of very large companies. A
third point, also on the political front, which I hadn't addressed before, is that we need to think
more about
our institutions. We have
institutions that are obviously
those of the Fifth Republic,
built in
1958, during the "thirty glorious years,"
institutions that work
very well when it comes to distributing 6%
growth in the country. We realize that with
3% growth, all they can
do is create debt
for 30 years, and when we reach 0%
growth, we realize that
obviously we can't take on any more debt.
And when we're told that we're supposed to
repay the debts of the last 30
years, we see...  That we can't manage it, and
this system also carries within it,
I find, a selection of those elected at the
national level, and of those who are truly in the
spotlight. So it's only
10 or 15% of the total, but there are 900 members of
parliament and senators. Well, we think about it
knowing some of them, and the others we don't know.
If I have someone there,
unfortunately, often in this person, to
reach these levels you are
forced to lie, to be
dishonest, well, you
select a few of the
most perverse individuals because to get elected, to be at the
top ahead of everyone
else, frankly, it's still
extremely difficult. It requires a
personal commitment that is
insane, and I think that no one
around this table is
really ready to face it. It's very difficult
today to be of service to one's
country. Well, in the
selection system, you select these
individuals, I call them the most perverse. We
realize this from time to time when we shine
a spotlight on them.  On some
banks by the majority, but still a
certain number by Bruce had
individuals who, by dint of being
dishonest with their voters,
end up being honest in Bamako,
period. So we need to
reflect on how we sanction them, and
in this system we realize that we no longer
sanction Yahoo. What will
Mr. Cahuzac get? Probably not much.
We're waiting for
last week, when they were thinking about
returning to the National Assembly. We're saying, "Hey, that's still
an
interesting sanction." You have this everywhere, the
subprime mortgages in the United States. Well, you had
thousands or tens of
thousands of false declarations against
unemployed people earning a thousand dollars a
month who declared ten thousand last year. No one
was prosecuted. The CEO who
sank Dexia, aptly named Pierre
Richard, continues to collect his pension
quietly. Hats off to him. Did he consult
a psychic? And perhaps we should also
explain that he
probably lied when he was
hired, since  I imagine he
declared himself competent, but
subsequent events showed that wasn't entirely the
case.
Anyway, I'm being a bit harsh, but there are more
sanctions in this system. The
abuses are significant and
charming, and obviously not sanctioned. The
financing doesn't work, so the
next guy continues. He didn't mention the
bank stress tests. In the middle of these
stress tests for the past four years, he
explained to us that Irish banks were
working really well, that Cypriot banks were working incredibly well,
that Dexia was working incredibly well. Where we
see that we've done whatever we want with
bank stress tests, and that Boya pressure, that the bear,
not so bad, wait for the day you
take a dozen consultants and
tell them – as sad as
a bank, if Hoult Bank gets
five years in prison, I guarantee you
the stress tests will be of high
quality. He simply laughs to
show you that the bank was already
bankrupt. It's often Mr. I
change my mind once on the way to
the march, MF Global,
the sanctions,
the mechanism that is  What happened
with Mev Global, Jon Corzine, and did he take
reggae advice? What kind of care would you
advise her to go to? I'll
leave you to leverage
MF Global. That's the problem with leverage,
meaning that at one point
you had, if I remember correctly, 35 or 36 times the
leverage. At some point
you make a
mistake and you're screwed. Stop it.
People need to realize this,
and Olivier is right, there were no
sanctions in 2008. The banks... we
felt the cannonball pass very, very
close to all of our heads
because of the banks. Did you see a
change? No, none at all. So we
happily continued to use almost the
same leverage. We
sometimes see some banks
increase their balance sheets. Société
Générale...
no lessons are learned, so you count...
and
in the same spirit, since
you don't face any sanctions anyway, you
can sink a bank, put 25,000
people out of work,
cost the community a few billion, and
you're not sanctioned.
Why would you want his
short-term recommendations to be
toughened? It's about toughening
sanctions,
doing what
Olivier asked for, what we've been demanding for a
very long time, which is to say, through
banking activity and
market activity, bring back a completely
airtight and
definitive glass-stealth system. These are all things that aren't being
done because,
ultimately, we realize, and then we're told, "
Yes, England has made the decision,
England has made the decision for
2017,
it won't be done." And
today we're talking about it in France.
Mr. Hollande, I believe,
spoke about it. Apparently, he forgot one of his
problems, Alzheimer's, I think, early on. So there you have it.
Because today you have
a
very powerful banking lobby, the banks have banded together,
and
today when you ask them for
something, they say it because they were
saved. And it was in 2008
that things really needed to be done.
Now they're here.  They
all seem to be in
great shape, and when you
ask them something, they say
no. They say no to two out of ten
years, Yves. If you bother us, we won't lend to
the economy anymore. It's been quite a while since they stopped
lending to the economy,
but it doesn't matter, they make you believe it.
And so, obviously, the minister in question goes into
his office. In ten years, above all, don't
bother,
the transition is around. He's coming in there,
precisely. Ethics, no, I was talking to you earlier about
the political career and
the
potential pressures from the financial world.
Your career, Mr. Lambert, has
allowed you to summarize
your thoughts, your
ideas on this, the different levers and
recommendations. It's possible to be
present here in your work.
Can you give us some avenues to explore, in
your opinion, to follow? First, I have to
build our armor to come back to what has just been
said. Okay, on the
separation of investment banking activities
and the number of deposits, of
course, we have to get there, we have to
redo a
layer of ice. There is, in France, it's
clear that...  that we made a joke about
bathing attendants on Thursday to finalize its
activities, they already are
anyway, so it's really according to the
general company, it only represents
0.5,000 military personnel,
said its president in front of me. I'm taking a
commission, it's perfectly justified to get me drunk,
sir, to tell you, here are seven
shots, the pleasure boating is really there,
pleasant and Dias Honda, well, it doesn't matter
about individualism, that's a subject that's still much
more important.
All current sociological studies
show that indeed there is this
immense return to individualism which is also
reflected in its
religious plan by the development of
sects, by the development of
evangelical churches. One is created every
two weeks in France. The evangelical churches, it was quite
astonishing because everyone makes their own
religion, taking a
little bit of Catholicism, Judaism,
Islam. Everyone
prepares their ideological propensity.
All this is true, is it
extraordinarily dangerous?  What is it that we
give a... I don't believe it.
We quickly realize, first of all, the return to
common coercive systems put in place
by people who quickly become
tyrants when, on the contrary, there is too much
convergence, as was the
case in the Soviet Union and in
Nazi Germany. Simply, once again,
we must frame all of this. It
gave him a sense of morality.
Beaumont, a somewhat crazy idea, once again,
to create his own tablets of the law.
On the level, they
are on the point, on the ethical level,
on the salary gaps. An anecdote:
when I was myself president of a
company,
my salary was 15 times that of the
milk company. Rumor has it I had the
lowest remuneration in the company. A few
years later, that was in the
70s and 80s. A few years later,
in the 90s, it was... because it went up
to 50, 60, 70. So I wrote a
long article in the newspaper,
a page, by the way, which never happened again, in which
I condemned those who...  The
gaps of 50, 70, 80, which already seemed
too high to me, and Fillon
had headlined it, and Lambert condemned the
salary gap of 1 to 70, is indeed
in place between 500 and 1 to 500, even a
friend today, and without anyone finding fault with it. In a
way,
it was called the business leaders
who benefit from it, how to say, are on
another planet, they don't live on
Earth, they don't realize
the effect produced by salaries of
this date, eyes that generate, let's say,
very strong feelings,
very strong tensions at the popular level, and that's
quite natural, and at the level of
the company itself, let's not exhale much,
even the state, DRAC had done
very interesting work on this, we see and
hear it, but this amnesty is in a way anesthetized,
or rather anesthetized,
earlier by stock options,
free share distributions, than the
wise one who, like at Kiki, only do what makes, who unites, the
managers, the
bosses, a certain number of executives, in
short, at its end  It's not much, admittedly, there are a
few crumbs given, but anyway, as is the case, when managers
start
having bosses who earn 100-200 times what they
earn today, you'll still get that same
feeling that was
very well described by Pléthore du Caire,
explaining a rather funny phrase: 110.
The problem with this isn't so much
that bosses have lost
the respect of their base salaries—well, strictly speaking, that never happens, and they
always think the
boss is a crook—but they are
losing the respect of senior managers, even
first-level executives, who think their
boss is, and was, a crook somewhere. What
they want is this
compensation, the slow recovery, knowing that they
themselves have
increasingly limited rewards. So, in
any case, it's very destructive
to the company's image, at least in
terms of loss of respect,
which would merit some
interesting sociological analysis. If you're
wondering, how can I put it? My
recommendations and implementation of  These are the
fortunate ones. If we were to talk about the
French situation, for example, what
needs to be done in France? Well, you
would expect
drastic, difficult measures, which
obviously include housing, a
customizable retirement system, or extending
working hours. Obviously,
unfortunately, we don't understand. We
need to take a break from
the evolution of all types of remuneration
because the unfortunate
tax credits following the
Gallois report only cover about a
third of the competitiveness gap that
exists between our economy and the
German economy. So the other two-thirds
must be found somewhere, perhaps through
a pause that is necessary
to allow companies to
rebuild their
self-financing capacity, in particular. In short, there are
a number of measures to take, all
relatively popular,
which, over two years, should be implemented
massively together and
allow us to
regain a form of
confidence and a glimmer of hope.
Simply, I don't believe that
politically, any
current government, left or right, is
capable of implementing them. Those that
remain will inevitably be...  Unpopular
as he was, whatever his political stance, whether left-wing
or right-wing, I'll say, is that in this
game, I advocate for
a kind of national unity government
of public salvation, representing
people of goodwill from both sides, composed of
moderate politicians. I know
some technocrats on both the left and the right;
they're not all as they say and
without merit, far from it. A
government would
implement all these measures for two years, and then, after
two years, well, that's it, the party's over, so to speak,
the
political battle resumes. At least we will have brought the
country back up to speed, and once again, it will
be tough, it will be a difficult effort.
The final word, others don't, but
once we are faced with situations that are perhaps quite
paradoxical—we were
talking about individualism earlier,
but we say, if I introduce too much
individualism, it ends up
disrupting the economic system. It will
create massive disorder, and we know very
well that the population, faced with
disorder, will choose order rather than...
Freedom, so it risks hindering
authoritarian regimes as well. The euro,
which we've been talking about, we often say is a bit
hasty. Europe is peace, okay,
maybe, but six months just because
Europe is peace, because the euro won't mean
war. The problem is that
it pushes some of them towards
nationalism, a return of
extremely significant selfishness in Europe when we
see what's happening today, how
Germans are perceived throughout
southern Europe, for good or
bad reasons, especially compared to what they had
five years ago.
So it doesn't seem to be heading towards
universal harmony in Europe, this
thing. So in conclusion, what to
do, or some ideas?
I really think we need to become
aware that
the phenomenal growth of the
financial sector over the last fifteen
years is something unhealthy. I do
n't like the term "financial" because it's
not a financial sector that has
developed, but a speculative one. It's a financial sector that
is indispensable. We need it.  What's
needed is that it's full of brilliant people, and
anyway, even in this whole
system, it's full of
brilliant people everywhere, but most of them
are working to ruin
the real economy, the
industrial economy. Note that we
need the industrial economy
to realize that this sector is
not healthy and that it needs to be
deflated quickly. We are very
far from that; we continue to consider it
almost a solution. There may be
banks that still have this type of
balance sheet over 4, 5, 15 years, which is healthy, and
that we absolutely must preserve all these
derivative products, which are
purely speculative products, a kind of
casino product that
endangers the entire economic system.
Unfortunately, the banking law, which we didn't talk about much earlier,
but which we can discuss in
the media, shows that unfortunately, the
conclusion is that the system is
not reformable. I'm sure the whole wheel had to be turned,
but by F1, without a
painful episode, obviously, but that we are
condemned to rebuild Liesberg a second
time, and perhaps at a cost.  of the system, and that's what's quite
frightening, because the banking law, when you
see the positions on the left, on the right, in the
center, will be settled quickly and efficiently.
We should have returned
to the separation of
banking activities, which, I remind you, was the
law in France between 1945 and, in practice,
1995. So all we're asking for  And so, it's like
going back to the banking landscape of 1995, where things weren't
working too badly. We realize
that because it's not possible, we mustn't
touch anything, especially since we're not
limiting the activities or the
traders' remuneration. Okay, very well,
you know, since there's no
strong popular pressure on this point, the bomb
is doomed. Indeed, as
Olivier Delamarche said two weeks ago, we're
all Cypriot. Well, that's what's in
front of us. It's a
shame because with a little
collective intelligence and a little
goodwill, we could undoubtedly have made much more
efficient decisions. And what
worries me is that sometimes I think, if we had randomly selected
100 people, held a mini-
assembly to present the problems,
they would have been able to make decisions
because people, individually, aren't
stupid, aren't completely
irresponsible. And when the
political system today can no longer manage,
undoubtedly also due to short-termism,
undoubtedly also due to a lack of sanctions,
undoubtedly also because  When you enter
politics at 35 and are 70, you'll
always be there, inevitably. This
forces you to act in a certain way that isn't at
all the one we'd expect, the one we'd
use.
We were only there for five years, this short-
termism. We really need to say something about it.
I mean, the effects are absolutely
disastrous. We've completely forgotten the
long term that should govern
the economy. This is evident in
countless phenomena.
Quarterly accounts mean we'll have
monthly accounts one day, or a
daily count. I'd even say it's
especially appreciated. They're
capable of doing daily accounts,
having hourly counts, I don't know. It's a
caricature, but it's if we
're in a system that's going
completely crazy
and that doesn't generate the
desire to invest in
research and development, the mother
of
innovation. But this is the main thing. So all this means that this
short-termism, to which
French companies are currently sacrificing their
research and
development, is decreasing compared to their
figures.  Business could allow for
the release of quarterly financial results that are
slightly more attractive than expected, so
they are doing what is necessary to release them, and
I believe it is up to the government, through
measures itself based on a
long-term perspective, to set an example and encourage
businesses to follow suit. But at this
stage, it would be necessary to change the culture
of all financial analysts in
rating agencies. Well, that won't happen overnight, especially since
the phenomenon originated in the
United States, and they are the ones who
hold, to some extent, the
levers of power in this area—
how to put it, intellectual power. The
problem is that it's a real
pair of nations in our
societal functioning. Inevitably, when we deregulated
in the 80s, if you deregulate, it
becomes a law of the jungle,
and therefore, to some extent, you are forced
to be short-termist because if you
are long-termist when facing
competitors who are
short-termist, you will lose. So
obviously, you have a development of
this short-term vision, therefore
wanting to make profits in the very short
term. In the financial sector, you
have ways of doing so.  Very short-
term gains that will sink the company in five
or ten years, but that's no longer your
problem since you yourselves are
managers who have been in
office for three or four years and are loaded with stock
options, which are therefore a kind of
enormous bet on the
stock market's performance and therefore on what analysts
will think of your stock. So this
system is unhealthy, and it's sad
because there are plenty of simple measures
that could be taken without
major difficulties with a little courage and
a little understanding of what's going on.
Why is it that if I make a
financial profit in 15 minutes or in fifteen years, it's the same? It's still
crazy! Why is it that if I join
a company today I can
vote at the general meeting tomorrow,
why will my vote tomorrow have the same, or even the
same weight, as a shareholder
who has been there for 15 years? We could
change that! Why do we count
the shares that have continued to trade on the stock exchange?
Why does
the value of the
company's stock change every millionth of a second? You have to be
crazy to believe that!  You could very well have just one
value per day, at least that would
eliminate all the speculation. Let's
say 20 other
daily jokes that serve absolutely no purpose.
Who can justify a
company's value fluctuating every
millisecond? It's
madness, and we could do this kind of thing.
95% of people agree, if
not 100%, we don't know, but
it's dramatic. It's the
simple measures that help, we do them because we don't do the
complicated ones either.
People do nothing, Father
Resto. And look, Liesberg
was calmly approaching us. That will
be the last word, perhaps. Olivier
Delamarche, a last word? Yes, we've
gone from governing is about planning to
governing is not about seeing your next
election.
[Music]